now what i want to do for the rc circuit
is a formal derivation of exactly what
these two curves look like
and then we'll have a
precise definition of the natural
response
what i want to do now is real quick draw
our circuit again
there's r there's c
and we have some initial voltage we said
on the capacitor
which is v naught
and what we want to find
is we want to find v of t
and there's r
and there's c
so let me also label the currents in
these guys
this is the current in the resistor
and this is the current
in the capacitor
so now i'm going to write the two
voltage current relationships for these
two components and ohm's law tells me
that
equals one over r
times v
and the current energies in a capacitor
this is i r
current in a capacitor is
equals c
times dv
dt
that's the two currents in our devices
now i'm going to use kirchhoff's current
law on this node right here
and that says that all the currents
flowing out of that node have to add up
to zero
so let's do that let's say
i
c
plus ir
equals zero
this is
k
c l kirkhof's current law
c
dv dt
plus
1 over r
times v equals 0.
now i'm just going to divide through by
c just to be tidy
dv dt
plus
1 over rc
times v
equals zero
so what we have here
this expression here is referred to as
an ordinary differential equation
it has a derivative in it and that's
what makes it a differential equation
and you can go look up you can go look
up ode and search for this in khan
academy and elsewhere
and
in the mathematical videos you'll find
out different ways to solve this
equation
now we're going to do the same thing
here
and what we're going to do is we're
going to try to find
an expression for v of t we're going to
define
v of t in a way
that makes this equation true so we plug
the function in here whatever it is and
then we take its derivative and plug
that in here and that has to make this
whole expression true
there's a couple of different ways to do
this and the one that we're going to use
here is we're going to guess at an
answer so what we need is
we need a function whose derivative
looks kind of like itself because this
thing has to add up to 0.
so that means that the function v and
the function
d of dv dt they have to be of the same
form so that they have a chance of
adding up to zero
the function that i know the whose
derivative looks like itself is the
exponential
so we're going to propose that there's
going to be an exponential
and the way we do it is we say we'll put
in some constant here that we can adjust
and then we'll put some constant out
here
so this is our guess our guess is going
to be
that
the solution for v of t is going to be
something of the form
some constant times e to another
constant s
times t
the way we test our guess is to put it
back into the equation and see if it
works
and if it does then we made a good guess
if it doesn't work then we have to go
back and try something else
so one of the things we need we're going
to plug v of t in right here
we're going to need derivative of v with
respect to time so let's take a
derivative here
equals
d dt of k e to the st
and that equals
k
and the s comes down
and e to the st remains
so we just took the derivative of our
proposed solution
and now we're going to plug it into the
equation and and see what happens
so now i'm going to plug in the
derivative that we had plus the proposed
solution and see if our equation comes
out true
so dv dt
is
s
k
e to the s t
plus
uh 1 over rc stays here
and we plug in v
and v was k
e to the
st and that all equals zero
now i'm going to factor out here's
here's the common term
for each one of these so we'll just
factor that out
so now we get k
e to the st
times
s
plus
1 over rc
equals zero
okay now let's take a little peek at
this
we have to make this zero by the way we
pick k
and s
all right how can we make this zero
there's three terms in here there's
three terms in a product there's this
this
and that
any three any three of these terms could
be zero okay the first one k is zero
that's a boring one because it just says
if we have a circuit with no energy it
sits there with no energy
so that's not so interesting
now e to the st
we can make that go to zero but
that's pretty takes a long time because
we have to let t go to infinity
s would have to be a negative number and
t would have to go to infinity which is
a long time to wait for something to
happen so that's not a very interesting
solution either so here's the
interesting one the interesting one is
when s plus rc equals zero
so the interesting solution is s
plus
one over rc
equals zero and that says that s
equals minus 1 over rc
that makes this solution true
and if that's the case
now we could say v of t
we're making good progress here
k sum k
times
e
to the minus t over
rc
now something really interesting just
happened here look up here where we have
this rc term here see this right here
this whole exponent has to have
no units by the time we evaluate it that
means that rc
has to have units of time
rc is a measure it's in seconds
rc is the units of r times c ohms times
ferrets is actually seconds this whole
exponent has to have no units
by the time we evaluate it and that
means that rc
has to have units of time and it's
actually ohms times fair ads comes out
to be seconds
now we solve for s and that means we
only have to find k
let's work on k now
k is a variable here time is a variable
and voltage is a variable if we knew v
and t
at the same time we would be able to
figure out k
and there's a time when we do know that
and that is t equals zero at t equals
zero
we know that the battery was hooked up
and there's about as a bunch of charge
on the capacitor so we know that the
voltage on the capacitor
at time 0
is equal to v naught
so now we have a pair of variables here
we know v and t at the same time so
let's plug that into our proposed
solution and see how k pops out
so we're going to put these two into our
proposed solution and see what happens
to k
v at time equals 0
is v naught
and that's equal to k
times e to the
minus
t
minus 0 at time 0 over rc
now this whole expression
is e to the 0 or 1
so it drops out of the
it drops out of the expression and all
we get is k
equals v naught
k is the starting voltage on the
capacitor
and that gives us to our final answer
which is
v of t
equals
v naught starting voltage
e to the minus
time over
rc
we can go one small step further and
find out what is i of t
well i of t
is equal to
v of t
over r
that's just ohm's law
and so i of t equals v naught
over r
e to the minus t
over rc
that is the natural response of an rc
circuit